the calculation of uh the simplest millionaire tax
that's uh
if you tax the assets above 1 million it 1%
yes,
the more than 3 and 1 / 2 billion live up
you can abolish the deductible
just to mention something
yes I want to but I just want to know what
what am I going to see in my wallet
just to name something you could do
I'm only talking about 1%
but imagine you really would
make progressive
and you will,
for example,
then look at morning
above 2 million or above 5 million
yes then you really get 1 higher yield
Uhm but with that
uh when we look at
the tax on work
which is really 1 lot higher than on capital
therefore also on assets or profits
we also see that in our country
uh uh well on the second time in the back follow
2022 but also 2023 the
390 billion euros in profit has been made
yes if we were going to tax that 1 little bit
then we can invest that herren
now it is often Lu lazy money in bank accounts
which is also of little use to our society
if we tax that 1 little bit
we can invest that herren
for example that public service
what I was just talking about
then our society has it as a whole
and I also want to say
the most power to the richest
they will then end up in 1 society
come and live with less tension
less inequality
and therefore also 1 pleasant society to live